sa tout le monde a ses ses difficultés
l'amour c'est pas c'est pas si facile tu
sais l'amour moi-même j'ai j'ai mes
petits
problèmes comme la boue comme la glaise
entre la mer et la falaise comme l'ombre
entre deux
chansons nous vivons entre
parenthèses on se rencontre entre de
trains bonjour bonsoir vous êtes belle
faut-il que la vie soit
cruelle bonsoir madame et à demain
entre le bémol et le diè toujours assis
entre deux chaises comme on dort entre
deux
frissons nous vivons entre
parenthès d'Amérique ou du Canada
bonjour bonsoir la ville est triste un
peu comme la vie d'artiste qui m'éloigne
toujours de
toi une gare
plaintive un avion une
auto qu'il fasse triste ou beau
j'attends que tu m'écrire
entre Nant et
Bordeaux que ce soit le 12 le 13 quel
que soit le jour qui nous plaise quand
on a l'amour des chansons l'amour est
une
parenthèse je t'aime entre deux
projecteurs bonjour bonsoir la salle est
pleine j'ai pas le temps d'avoir de la
peine je te remercie pour tes
fleurs pourtant avant les pluies
d'automne avant de nêtre plus personne
que des phrases dans mes chansons je
fermerai la
parenthèse qui t'a ne plus jamais
chanter tant pis si j'y laisse mon âme
tu ne seras pas une femme qui se
conjugue au temps
passés comme la boue comme la glaise
entre la mer et la falaise comme l'ombre
entre deux
chansons nous vivons entre
parenthèses on se rencontre entre de
trains bonjour bonsoir vous êtes belle
faut-il que ma vie soit
cruel bonsoir
madame et à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain